nouveau coup de tonnerre pour huawei
après une réunion du conseil de sécurité
nationale présidé par boris johnson
le royaume uni a fait le choix d'exclure
le géant chinois de son réseau 5 g selon
le ministre britannique chargé de la
culture et du numérique
cette décision a pour but de sécuriser
le réseau du pays le gouvernement est
d'accord avec l'avis du centre nationale
de cybersécurité
la meilleure façon de sécuriser nos
réseaux et que les opérateurs cesse
d'utiliser les nouveaux équipements de
huawei concernés pour construire les
futurs réseaux 5g du royaume uni donc
pour être clair à partir de la fin de
cette année les opérateurs de
télécommunications ne doivent plus
acheter d'équipement 5 ga huawei et une
fois que la loi sur la sécurité des
télécommunications sera adopté il sera
illégal pour eux de le faire
une décision influencé par les sanctions
américaines contre le géant chinois en
mai dernier les états unis ont prolongé
d'un an l'embargo empêchant huawei de
collaborer avec des entreprises
américaines
avant même l'annoncé de londres la chine
a réagi ce mardi à une éventuelle mesure
punitive britannique nouveau la question
de savoir si le royaume uni peut offrir
un environnement commercial ouvert
équitable et non discriminatoire aux
entreprises chinoises sera la pierre de
touche de la tendance du marché
britannique après ben rexie ainsi qu'un
baromètre de la sécurité des
investissements chinois au royaume uni
la chine y prêtera une attention
particulière des paroles lourdes de sens
qui laisse entrevoir une riposte de la
part de pékin
les tensions ne cessent de monter entre
les deux pays notamment au sujet de hong
kong en cause
l'entrée en vigueur d'une loi de
sécurité contesté dans le territoire
semi-autonome début juillet boris
johnson a confirmé son intention de
permettre à des hong kong et de
s'installer pendant au moins cinq ans au
royaume uni et de son côté jérémy
thompson vice président de huawei
royaume uni ne cache pas sa déception
écouter personnellement je suis
extrêmement déçu par la décision du
gouvernement britannique des nuits la
politique qui a été établi il ya
seulement quelques mois le 28 janvier de
cette année
je pense que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour les consommateurs britanniques car
vous savez ils ressentiront l'impact sur
leurs téléphones et leurs factures de
téléphone la connectivité et les coûts
associés
donc c'est une déception et une mauvaise
nouvelle